we all want to be happy but the majority
of us have no idea what to do see the
Japanese have a concept called ikigai
which roughly translates into a reason
for being you need to have a purpose for
being here but this is easier said than
done because there are four components
that you need to check off in order to
achieve ikigai now the interesting thing
about this Japanese formula is that you
can tell where you are in life and what
you need to work on by looking at the
components you have so far if all you
have is something that you love and are
good at then you have what's called a
passion on the other hand if you have
something that you love and you can see
how the world needs it then you have
what's called a mission now if you're
someone who has something you get paid
well for and are good at then you have
what most people in the world have which
is a profession and finally if you get
paid well and it's something that you
know can help the world then you have
what's called a vocation you need to be
spending your time doing something that
you love that you can get better at that
pays well and that the world needs
without all four you will always feel
like you're missing something inside of
you follow us for more helpful tips